hi today I'd like to talk to you about a
new module called signals and systems
our previous module on programming we
focused on object-oriented programming
and state machines as different methods
by which we could model the physical
world in this module we're going to talk
about a new way to model the physical
world called the discrete linear
time-invariant system you might say
Kendra why do I need to do that or why
would I move away from state machines I
seem to be able to model everything
using state machines the short answer is
you want to be able to move away from
state machines because you want to be
able to predict the future but are not
really going to be able to get to how
you're gonna be able to predict the
future until two videos from now so for
now we'll introduce discrete linear
time-invariant systems and also talk
about different knowledge
representations you might encounter them
in so that you recognize them when you
see them and can manipulate them as
needed to you know talk to other people
about them let's go to the board last
time we talked about state machines
we're able to use them to model pretty
much any system we can model the
evolution of a particular process over
time using a record of all previous
inputs and outputs and possibly previous
states if we include that in our output
but the problem with state machines is
that they they like most programming
encounter the halting problem right at
some point your program can reach a
little complexity at which you cannot
determine what it's going to do without
actually just running it and seeing what
happens this is great for researchers
right this is you know the method by
which people go out and have to like
find something or discover something
instead of being able to like simulate
it using a machine but if you want to be
able to promise things other people or
you know predict what's going to happen
then it helps if you can model something
that has a high level of complexity by
abstracting away the complexity and
interacting with it as though it has
features that indicate that it's going
to behave in a particular way so if you
want to make a control system that does
a particular thing or look at an
existing system and say well I know that
you're you know you know your power
plants going to blow up in five
because of this it helps if you have
some understanding of particular classes
of systems and what those particular
classes of systems what kind of
long-term behaviors those particular
classes of systems generate and that's
why we will look at discrete LTI it's a
particular class of system in particular
discrete LTI is what we're gonna look at
6:01 because it's fairly simple but once
you've learned how to deal with the
system in that manner you can use the
skills that you've learned there to
approach more complex feedback problems
or more complex control problems first
an incredibly brief review of linear
time-invariant systems when you're
talking about a linear time-invariant
system both the inputs and the outputs
are going to be real we're not going to
deal with the complex plane at all if
you were to model your LTI system using
a state machine that state machine would
be to dependent on a fixed amount of
previous inputs outputs or states you
give some amount of leeway for start
state or the fixed number of states
before you get to your fixed amount of
data structure that represents your
current state but if you're running a
linear time-invariant system the amount
of information that you need to figure
out your state in a long-term sense is
always finite and fixed in terms of
functional expressions you've probably
seen these associated with linear
time-invariant systems note that this
also means that you can represent linear
time-invariant systems as additions or
scalar multiplications of your existing
function so that's out of the way these
are all true of LTI we're gonna focus on
discrete LTI one because we can use a
discrete state machine to model it and
to because it makes it easier to
represent using computers right once
you've got that digital abstraction you
don't have to worry about having access
to a truly continuous function
all right now that you know what we're
gonna talk about how do you talk about
it to other people here the different
representations that you might see a
discrete linear time-invariant system in
one of them is called a difference
equation and you've probably encountered
this and like one of your math classes
it says that you're going to take a
sample from a signal Y at some sort of
Givens time step
typically N and when you're writing out
a difference equation that represents an
entire system you'll usually see Y of n
on one side on the left and then
everything that represents the
functional component on the system on
the right which in this case determines
what determines the output at every time
step in this very particular case we're
talking about an accumulator which means
that at every time step the output is
determined by the input plus the
previous output so at every time step we
take the input and whatever it is we
were outputting before and I'll put it
again pretty straightforward if somebody
described a difference if somebody
described to you a difference equation
words you could probably turn it into
equation to this point note that even
though there are variables associated
with these samples they're still very
particular samples and the thing that
you're interested in is probably not
even the samples at all it's the
relationship between the samples when
they are sampled and relative to one
another and how that relates to the
output at a given time step if you then
want to talk about an entire signal then
you can use an operator equation and
you'll probably see these things when
you do any sort of research on control
theory or feedback instead of
representing the sample of the signal Y
at a given time n we're just going to
talk about the overall signal Capital y
likewise instead of talking about X at a
given time n we're going to talk about
the signal Capital X
remember that I said that the most
important part of this equation is the
fact that there's a different
relationship between these two signals
and when you are sampling from them when
we want to represent this relative delay
we use it we represent it using an R and
in particular I want to note the fact
that the degree of R represents the
amount of delay associated with the
sample from a particular signal so if I
wanted to make this n minus 2 I would
reflect that change in my operator
equation by changing the degree of our
and because we're working with a linear
time-invariant system if we wanted to
scale this by 2 it'd be the same as
scaling this by 2 etc
now I can talk about signals what if I
want to talk about a physical
manifestation of the relationship
between these signals and or what if I
want to use something kind of like
circuit diagrams to talk about what kind
of signal manipulation I'm going to do
this is where block diagrams come in
block diagrams are incredibly powerful
at point friendly block diagrams mean
that everybody is on the same page
because all you have to do is trace out
the arrows block diagrams mean that
you're going to do a combination of
gains delays and adders to visually
represent the relationship between your
output signal and any input signals that
you have up here I have actually drawn
an accumulator and it's got a box around
it in part because which will be
relevant in two minutes but right now
you can ignore it I've got my input
signal or my input signals are typically
on the left and the progression of gains
delays matters associated with the block
diagram represent the relationship
between the input signals and the output
signal and then I'll have my output
signal on the right most people will
indicate flow with arrows and part to
make things easier to read but typically
you only need the arrow indicating where
you're sampling from and what your
output is going to look like in this
case in order to get why and in the
general sense I can back-trace from the
signal that I'm interested in through my
diagram and figure out what values I'm
actually interested in so in this
particular case Y is a linear
combination of X and whatever this
represents which is our Y
if I did want to put it to here I've
been talking about gains delays matters
but this diagram doesn't contain a game
yet so let me show you how you would
include a game gains are typically
represented by the value of the game
inside an arrow it looks like an op amp
from schematic diagrams we'll get to
those later in circuits it's not
essential that the arrow point in the
direction of flow but people might look
at you funny if you don't put it in the
direction of flow and the other thing
that I think I want to note here is that
if you see a minus sign here it means X
minus 2r y which is the same as putting
a negative value on your game so right
now we're back to X plus 2 our Y okay
we've got two block diagrams you might
be saying at this point Kendra what are
block diagrams good for other than
PowerPoint presentations and possibly
arguing with my friends over what's
going on and I say they're really good
for abstraction
I can draw a box around this and
abstract it away into a function and say
if I put something into this box and I
want to get something out where the
action that happens in here is identical
to this schematic then I can find an
equation that actually represents that
operation and the way I do that is I'm
going to take my operator equation and
solve in particular for Y over X in this
case with the two Y over X is going to
be 1 of minus 1 over 1 minus 2r
note that at age if H is equal to the
expression Y over X and I multiply H by
X I get out why this concludes my
coverage of motivations for learning
about discrete LTI systems and also the
different representations that we'll
want to use when talking to other people
about discrete LTI at this point we can
also start talking about how we get to
the point where we can start predicting
the future and then in the video after
that I'll actually start talking about
poles